[Music]
well detective Hayes could you tell us
your timeline of events they were silver
black to me
was just a case on our card
I know it'd be my two kids supposed to
be home by 5:30 never arrived almost had
a clean knife
is this a don't you tell me about wheel
he's quiet
I don't think he got nervous much
[Music]
I'm telling you they didn't run off all
you had to do was watch it it's bad if
you look around are you gonna wear that
badge got a little clip on
looks like you haven't slept in a couple
days I'll never stop coming up with
theories about that case my job there's
no certainty
well you don't remember you don't know
you don't know they don't did you think
you could just go on and never once
my whole brand's much missing pieces you
ever been someplace you couldn't leave
you couldn't stay both at the same time
things I've seen
things are known
a lot of people around this they're dead
a lot of people gone must be great
Avenue room ever you think you did or
didn't do you know deserve to suffer
[Music]
let's taste so I could think of don't
wanna know the whole story
[Music]
[Music]